should we do this okay has anyone got
any ideas as to how they might go about
proving that this is theater any takers
okay so we had these parallel lines
before right I should be able to make
some arguments about other angles in
there not just the corresponding ones
okay
so there's our first idea Eric did you
have a similar idea or different yeah
okay so um we could get the gradient of
a few lines and do that angle stuff
which i think is that's the technical
phrase for this right like angle of
incidence and that angles like that that
works fine for me okay yeah these are
all these are all fine plausible
arguments okay the way I'm going to go
about this is neither of those which
doesn't mean that those are the both
wrong but it might be quicker and use
the tools that we have at our disposal a
little more easily okay have a look at s
KP s KP the angle that we started with
and we call that theta right do you
notice that angle s KP is in triangle s
K P yeah you see the triangle there in
fact I'm gonna encourage you if you have
another color so I'll draw that triangle
outline that triangle so you can see
what we're working with here now I've
said this before in any kind of proof
that we've ever had to do whether it's
geometry or trig identities that kind of
thing if you're asked to prove something
is true it is often helpful to not
assume but imagine that it is true and
think about what that will mean and
therefore what you can use to try and
get to your result right if this really
is theta then what kind of triangle is
skp it's isosceles right so if I can
prove that it's isosceles then I'm done
that I'm pretty much established
okay now isosceles in which way like
which of the sides that should be equal
s K and s P right now I know everything
about s K and P I know all the
coordinates so this actually should be
fairly easy right let's have a go
Espie the length right I've got two
coordinates so I can just use the
distance formula it's a square root of
what don't quote the formula for me tell
me what it is in this case okay let's do
the x-coordinates to AP minus zero
squared right plus AP squared minus a
squared
yeah have a go off you go
do some work
[Applause]
did you get that
here's my atop ya know
why does it not become to a split-second
mind
you mean this where does that term come
from
what's that equal to
mm-hmm so the term you're referring to
which of these terms is it does that
answer your question did anyone get what
I got a small number okay let's let's
just quickly walk through just to make
sure we're all on the same page okay
from here to here all I have done is
expand okay this is just squared squared
squared here you've got a you square the
first term you square the last term and
this is the minus double of the product
okay but then I noticed that there's a
squared P squared in from both of those
right so I can do a bit of canceling the
cancelling any that is here now from
this point you could do two different
things
oh that's an underestimation then you
can do a lot of different things but the
most common things you would do are
either what I did which is I took out a
factor of a how did I do that why do I
should ask why do I do that yeah because
there's an a squared every single time
here right so if i factor out a squared
then I can take out a but do note
actually you can't unless this is true
can anyone tell me why I have to say
that maybe you won't lose a mark but if
you want mathematically accurate you
should say that any suggestions hmm what
I've taken out is not actually a what
I've taken out is this do you agree like
there's a square root there's an a
squared this is not necessarily a right
this is actually think back to the
beginning of you this is the absolute
value of it
okay now the absolute value of a is a in
a certain case namely when a is positive
what is a what is a is the focal length
which is a distance okay so that's why
I'm good otherwise I have to have
absolute now you like our lines here
when you have a look at this
you're like oh that's a perfect square
hopefully you can recognize that you
shouldn't be that surprised because it
came from a lot of squared stuff and I
can do the same thing here but again so
that there's no absolute value signs I
should say this by the way why is this
true different reason because P doesn't
have to be positive piece the parameter
it's the gradient it can be anything you
like so why is that going to be positive
very good you square it and then just to
be sure you're also add one all right so
therefore that guy is definitely
positive so like don't have to worry
about the absolute value signs okay
are we there you happy so I got SP that
was this distance over here what why not
do that again I'm trying to prove that
it's isosceles so hopefully this guy
over here is also the same length okay
so how am I gonna find that well SK I
could go ahead and I could do the
two-point distance formula because I
have the coordinates but I don't have to
do that do you notice that this is the
origin right this is the origin here do
you agree that SK is made up of s oh and
okay that's okay everyone's going um
do you agree is that okay you happy with
that so tell me what s Oh tell me what
that length is equal to it's a because
it's a vertical distance and that's the
vertical coordinate tell me what okay is
equal to be careful it's a length right
it's a length the - tells me what
direction it's in it tells me it's down
here
but what tells me how far away it is is
the AP squared is that okay no distance
formula required okay so this is I can
take out my factor now what I was
searching for yes agreed that is P yes
okay so I I'm not going to complete the
proof now because we're pretty much
there I've shown that this is an
isosceles triangle which means that the
opposite sorry the equal sides produce
equal angles so now I've got these guys
which mean that this is true
so just returning back to where's my
picture there we go here we go just
returning back to this what's going on
well have a look back at the focus again
do you see where the focus is now areas
all right every rays coming down through
this dish from the same direction it's
coming downward in proportion to where
it's angled right and every single spot
that collects that bounce off bounces
off a arm a signal bounces them all off
to exactly the same point the focus
likewise if we have a think about the
headlight it's doing the same thing but
in Reverse so this little lighting
element here is producing light that
goes everywhere it goes everywhere just
like I didn't bring my phone with me can
I remember oh this thank you
eh mm-hmm a normal point light source
just goes everywhere right which is why
if I put my hand up over here I don't
need to put my hand up you can see have
a look at that shape what is that shape
it's it's like roughly circular and it
just sort of fades away as you get
further away because life it comes from
here has got to go further to get to
this point than it does to get here so
that's why this parts darker in this
part slider right it's going everywhere
but if you have this kind of shape here
all the lights not just going everywhere
it goes everywhere but then it all goes
in one beam all in the same direction
which is exactly what you want
headlights to do otherwise everyone's
just going to go blind okay so we can
really nicely visualize this by getting
a full screen and just moving around
what happens when you see that angle of
that ray there just kind of shifting
around but always either going into or
coming out of the focus and this is
one of the many reasons why we so love
parabolas okay